I've visited over 125 countries and I've
been to all seven continents of the
world
hold on Jerusalem and I've seen nothing
my name is Tony Giles I'm totally blind
so very deaf yeah I travel the world
alone I come from South West England
founded I think I was born with a rare
eye condition I could see shapes and
shadows a very light-sensitive as a
child but by the time I was 8 9 my light
sensitivity was going when I was 16 and
I got the opportunity to go to the
States and I was all excited that's what
I really loved I loved the adventure and
the unknown before well I'm gonna travel
for the rest of my life and see if I can
visit every country in the world so I
thought I need to take photo so I got
actual evidence I've been there and I
also think it's quite a fire telling
public for see a blind person taking
photos that was sort of like mess where
their heads I find that quite
interesting people think how can you
travel when you're blind and how can you
do all these countries I got the series
of different maps on my walls
so I've got an idea what each country
I'm visiting looks like very on the
coast I researched the country I visit
so I go and I get on the Internet pound
equals and then I look at you say well I
want to visit museums or churches or
mosques and I try and find places we've
audio guides and in terms of it they
obviously there's a blind person I'm not
gonna go and see a country under
interested then looking at the beautiful
vistas so I need to walk places I need
to feel the atmosphere such things I
rely on people and everywhere I go to
help me she'd be my friend you take this
off a lot of countries over visit
obviously English in the first language
so for instance I lost the
the stuff to write down in Arabic the
places I want to go I meet people on the
streets and they give me directions or
they help me to go to places people ask
me oh all places you visit it's the same
because you can't see them but now maybe
every city every times every country is
different the thing I love about it most
is moving and actually getting from one
place to another that challenge so once
you actually sort of reach reach the
destination in a place you're looking
for that's a huge achievement yeah
that's that's why I do it let's see what
some of the reasons for my travels are
ready
[Music]